we are asked to find the cube root of
negative 512 or another way to think
about it is if I have some number and it
is equal to the cube root of negative
512 this just means that if I take that
number and I raise it to the third power
then I get negative 512 and if it
doesn't jump out at you immediately what
this is what is what this is the cube of
or what we have to raise to the third
power to get negative 512 the best thing
to do is to get it just do a prime
factorization of it and before we do a
prime factorization of it and to see
which of these factors show up at least
three times let's at least think about
the negative part a little bit so
negative 512 that's the same thing so
let me rewrite the expression this is
the same thing as the cube root of
negative 1 times 512 which is the same
thing as the cube root which is the same
thing as the cube root of negative 1
times the cube root cube root of 512 and
this one's pretty straightforward to
answer what number when I raise it to
the third power do I get negative one
well I get negative one
this right here is negative one negative
1 to the third power is equal to
negative one times negative one times
negative one which is equal to negative
one so the cube root of negative 1 is
negative one so it becomes negative one
times times this business right here
times the cube root cube root of 512 and
let's think what this might be so let's
let's do the prime factorization so 512
is 2 times 256 256 is 2 times 128 128 is
2 times 64 we already see a 2 3 times
64 is 64 is 2 times 32 32 is 2 times 16
we're getting a lot of twos here 16 is 2
times 2 times 8 8 is 8 is 2 times 2
times 4 and 4 is 2 times 2 so we got a
lot of tubes if you multiply so
essentially
you multiply two one two three four five
six seven eight nine times you're going
to get 512 or two to the ninth power is
512 and that by itself should give you a
clue of what the cube root is but
another way to think about it is can we
find there's definitely three twos here
but can we find it three groups of twos
or can we if we can also find let me
look at that look at it this way we can
find it three groups of two twos over
here so that's two times two is four two
times two is four so definitely 4
multiplied by itself three times is
divisible into this but even better it
looks like we can get three groups of
three twos so one group two groups and
three groups so each of these groups 2
times 2 times 2 that's 8 that is 8 this
is 2 times 2 times 2 that's 8 and this
is also 2 times 2 times 2 so that's 8 so
we could write 512 as being equal to 8
times 8 times 8 and so we can rewrite
this expression right over here as the
cube root of 8 times 8 times 8 so this
is equal to this is equal to negative 1
or I could just put a negative sign here
negative 1 times the cube root the cube
root of 8 times 8 times 8 so we're
asking our question what number can be
multiplied by itself three times or
ticket to the third power to get 512
which is the same thing as 8 times 8
times 8 well clearly this is 8 so the
answer this part right over here is just
going to simplify to 8 and so our answer
to this the cube root of negative 512 is
negative is negative 8 and we are done
and you can verify this multiply
negative 8 times itself 3 times well
let's just do it negative 8 negative 8
times negative 8 times negative 8
negative 8 times negative 8 is positive
64 you multiply that times negative 8
you get negative 512